you can win every sale that's the
superpower and that's where you do make
the most sales and this is what we have
to walk through with our prospects when
you're looking at them you have to be
like i don't want you to buy i want you
to decide for you not for me i'll be the
same either way right you're like i'm
going to be ripping in shape it's not
going to change me but like it will
change for you so quick note on sales
ethics and then we'll dive in helping
someone make a decision to help
themselves does not mean buying from me
that's a reiteration you have to keep
their goals at the center of the
decision and you should be happy if you
can be happy when someone decides to own
the power and not work with you then the
pressure around sales disappears it
evaporates there's no stake the stake is
did i help them that means that you can
win every sale because you change the
metric you're measuring yourself by
that's the superpower and that's where
you do make the most sales because you
don't care about the sale because you
care about the person and the people pay
the people who pay the most attention so
i call it paying attention they pay for
it they pay for you to pay attention
rather than talking about yourself